television screen an envelope or a
canvas are all examples of quadrilateral
quadrilateral is one word but you can
see that this part is colored red and
this part is coloured blue quadri
basically means four and lateral means
sides if you observe all these things
have four sides this is an example of a
quadrilateral to name the quadrilateral
we give names to these four points we
call them a B C and D these things that
we just named are called vertices and
the quadrilateral will always have four
vertices each point is called the vertex
and as we've already seen a
quadrilateral has four sides and the
sides are called a b b c c d and da so
remember every quadrilateral has four
sides and four vertices there is another
important property of quadrilaterals
consider this table the surface of this
table is flat it's a plain surface if I
draw a quadrilateral on a table it will
look something like this if you look at
the quadrilateral closely you can see
that all the vertices and sides of the
quadrilateral lie on one plane so a
quadrilateral has four sides four
vertices and is a closed figure lying on
one plane observe that a vertex is
formed when two sides meet at a point
and what is formed between those sides
is called an anger this is an anger a
quadrilateral is also defined by its
angles it has four angles apart from the
one we marked this one this one and this
one these are the four angles formed in
a quadrilateral but how do we name the
angles how can we name this green angle
well we
call it angle a we just named the angle
based on the vertex at which it is
formed but a better way to name it is to
call it angle D a B or you can also call
it angle B ad in these two cases we
named it based on the sides similarly
this angle can be called angle ABC this
one can be called angle BCD and this one
angle CDA and here's the last basic
concept you need to know in this
quadrilateral vertices a and C are
opposite to each other and vertices B
and D are opposite to each other the
lines joining the opposite vertices are
called the diagonals of the
quadrilateral so these two lines are
called the diagonals in this figure we
can say that AC and BD are the diagonals
what are its practical applications when
you watch this video on a 17 inch laptop
what you think is 17 inches it's the
length of the diagonal even when you
watch your favorite TV series on a 51
inch TV it's the diagonal that is 51
inches so remember a quadrilateral is a
closed figure on one plane which has
four sides four vertices and four angles
you